Well, if everybody do another Zoom call, if you're new, there's a few new people on, you are entering
muted. So your microphone is muted.
Most people keep it muted, and then if they have a question as they
get it in, you know, they didn't, they didn't, were able to send the question in prior to
or you're thinking of a question while we're chatting, you'll have to use the chat. So the
mute part of the Zoom message, you could just chat in your question, and then we'll get to it there
too. You can certainly unmute yourself and speak too, but you'd have to unmute yourself in order
to speak. Okay, so welcome to the other Zoom call, remember the members homepage, you'll see any new
announcements. I didn't have any new announcements, though I should post an announcement because I
going to give you an announcement right now. So forever also that you could self-schedule
pity calls on the member site or for that matter on our website as well. For those that have the
Atelier Robin machine, the picture that you see here is this is a, these little beads, these little
clip-on things on wires. You've all seen these, you have electrical devices that have these, not as
big as these because these wires are thick, but you your computer probably has it, your computer
cord has it, your, your, your different charging cords might have all sorts of electrical device
have these things. They're called ferrite cores or ferrite beads. I put a video up about them on
the frequency course on the first module and frequency course explaining that what ferrite beads do
or ferrite cords, cores, C-O-R-E-S, what they do is they help mitigate electrostatic electricity.
So when you are running electricity through cords that that that some of that could be dispersed
out as electromagnetic frequencies. Some of it can occur, especially in its running frequencies can
pick up static electricity in your home. It can create static electricity in your home. It can pick
up radio frequencies in your home and it can end up damaging devices. That's why a lot of electronics
will have these ferrite cords that are, many of them are built into the wire so they're like encased
in the wire. So it just looks like a little bump in your wire. You probably don't even notice them now
that I'm speaking of this. You might go, oh, I see that on this cord or that cord that I have.
They're very common and they're there. They're made up of ferrite, of an iod and it's there to reduce
static electricity and it's there to prevent any damage to electronics and to reduce loss in the
conductivity. I remember years ago where we lived in a place where our phone wasn't
real receptive, you know, our phone. And we had to, the phone company sent out these little
things that should clip on the wires and it would help prevent that static electricity that the phone
would come in much clearer. That's what these things are. So understand that we are putting these on
all of the bulbs to the connection area and then to right up by the bulb, you can't really see it in
this picture. It's up there in the container. I didn't take a very good picture of that. So there's
actually four on each bulb. So it's on the cord. It's two right by where you'd connected it into the
right machine and two up by the bulb. We're doing this on all the new bulbs that we're sending out.
And it's more important on, it would be good to have these on your true right bulbs and things to
help protect the equipment and help clean up the frequencies that are being sent to the bulb. But it's
more important with you actually a Robin because they tell you Robin is, you know, running at three
times the voltage. So you're getting a lot more voltage going through those wires, a lot more
ability to pick up static at radio frequencies and could, you know, feed back to the machine.
Now, anybody who's old to write true right or new people that haven't touched
until your Robin probably haven't experienced this yet. But for years, people have said,
well, I'm running the rife and it's something weird with the program. It's running the bulb,
but the timer on the timing down the program isn't working or it's timing up or it's being goofy.
It's because the frequencies, you're running frequencies through this bulb. And if your bulb is too close
to the computer, it can make your computer go goofy. And it can throw off whatever you're running
on the computer. And if you're currently just running the right program, which you're supposed to be
only running on your right computer, it can throw off that timer on there. And, you know, people can
get all upset. Well, it's running. The bulb is running, but it's, the timer isn't working. Okay,
that's why we have told you to, to not look at that. You're supposed to hit run
on your computer and then you're supposed to close the laptop for multiple reasons. Number one,
you don't want any EMS from your laptop. So as soon as you hit run on your computer for both the
Atelier Robin and the true rife, it sends the program that you hit run on. It sends that program
to the machine. You can literally pull the USB cable out. You can take the computer in the other
room. The computer is doing nothing, except you lose the commands of the computer. In the case you
wanted to hit stop or pause or case you wanted, oh, that was a wrong program. You said stop and you
go back to do something else. But if you hit the right program and hit run, you're supposed to close the
computer so you're not getting any A, you're not getting any EMS from the computer and B, you're not
getting any feedback from the frequencies that you're running because you are running these very
powerful frequencies can affect your computer. This is why we also tell you not to run. It's better
if you're not using your cell phone while you're running your rife either because sometimes your cell
phone will start acting goofy and things, especially if you're running frequencies that specifically
can affect your phone. Understand, frequencies are waves. So, think of it this way. Anything that's
running frequencies, which is any electronic device, including your folder, your laptop, is producing
frequencies. You're producing very specific frequencies via light through the rife machine.
What you're doing, so think of it this way, it's like if you're standing at a very still
pond and you throw a pebble in the pond, pebble hits and waves go out all directions from that pebble.
But now at the same time, you throw that pebble, you throw another pebble and it lands 20 inches away
from that and now these waves hit these waves that intersect affect each other and they can cancel
each other at the same frequency, meaning the exact same size pebble and they hit at the same time.
They could literally, the wave theory of physics, they could cancel out each other, it could affect
each other. Now you're not going to cancel out the frequencies from the rife machine, but you can
affect your cell phone. You could affect your computer and things, so that's why we tell you to close
your computer and it's best not to use your cell phone. The benefit of using the fair-eyed beads
is that you're not also picking up static electricity or dirty electricity from your house that could
damage your bone, that could damage your machine, or could affect possibly the quality of the
frequencies that you're trying to run through the ball. We just started doing this. If you're like
oh, I don't have those on my ball, we're going to be sending them out to people and I know we didn't
put it on it, but I may cross over because I just started doing this a few weeks ago, and you might
have a bomb that has it on there and you might get it envelope from us with these in there
that you're like already have them, so just keep them. So, hey, I'll do it. If you have a
true right, and you're listening to me, and you want to add these, you can. We have to charge you
for them. They cost us money. You don't really need them. You've been doing it without for a year or
two, but you can buy them. They're fairly cheap on Amazon. They're nine millimeter, fair-eyed
cores. You could buy a pack of them for $10 and put them on your equipment.
We're good to have really all your equipment, any electronic equipment,
television, anything. It could protect against surges and things. They're beneficial. So,
something to think about. What I should relate to this is running my right by the generator or
inverter. Yes. Okay. Yes. You're still getting 110 volts of electricity, 120 volts of electricity,
and you can power up your machine, then you could run the rice. Yep. No problem.
And then did I understand you to say that once we close the laptop after turning the right
program out, that we don't need to be concerned about the EFS or the laptop. That's correct. Yep.
Now, I do have a video that's actually your laptop doesn't produce that much EFS
radiation, in close to what your cell phone produces. But still, it's better to close it.
You then you won't really issues with EFS because once you close your laptop, it'll go to sleep
and it won't be running. You also should have your laptop on airplane mode. In case I messed up and
didn't do that. When I sent it to you, I always tried to remember to switch it to airplane mode before
I send it to you. If you have your laptop on airplane mode, then it won't be trying to pick up
an IP address in your home. So, it won't be searching for that. It's going to produce a lot less EFS
as well. As you see, the in Terra care hurts one at a separate time from the right
interfere with the treatment, right treatment. So, you're talking about a different device. No,
it doesn't interfere with the right treatment. If you're using a Terra care wand or if you're using
a PEMF, you can do that. The difference is you're using light frequencies and a totally different
frequency range. Any PEMF type device is using frequencies that about literally 1 to 10 hertz versus,
you know, you can see the hertz value of your frequencies varies anywhere between 30 and 30,000 hertz.
So, you're not going to have any effect on that frequency. And then I'll finish this last question
on here. Have you been reading? I've been reading that milk distil is not good for hormone positive
breast cancer. If you have a question about that, would hot-cut be better? So, milk distil is usually
used to help support phase one and two phase two, mainly phase one detoxification pathways in the
liver. Can there be an interruption with hormone positive breast cancer? There's some data about that
also. There's some data about adaptogens possibly being at interference with breast cancer,
hormone positive breast cancers. Really, the ashwaganda is the issue not so much the other adaptogens.
Yeah, if you want to be absolutely protective, there's other ways to support those pathways.
And certainly, if you wanted to switch to tonka, that is another way to help support your liver pathways.
I'll come back to those questions after I finish the questions that were submitted.
Okay, I'm getting close to finishing the 90-day supply of 30 milligram hypermected once a day.
Also taking bio-available bedbed 220 milligrams four days on three days off for the past two months.
I just recently raised it to 330 milligrams four days on three days off. I've been through a roller
coaster of pains in my spine, of which I'm a bit hudged over and cannot stand for very long.
Although I can walk, I am able to sleep flat on my back. Also, I'm standing on the word of God
that by his stripes, I was healed. You think I should continue with hypermected,
or could I just take the fenmenna and keep increasing it monthly? If I do
the hypermected would be better to take the 12 milligrams three times a day instead of the 30 milligrams
once a day. So the way you want to judge whether you're going to continue
a application of care is based upon subjective and objective finding. So the person that's asking this,
I think I remember, is a person that has metastasis through their spine. That's why they're mentioning
their spine. And yes, I think so. So the way I would decide whether I want to continue
hypermectin, first of all, I don't think that 30 milligrams hypermectin is quite a high in a dose.
So remember, the dose of hypermectin for cancer is supposed to be one half milligrams.
Per day per kilogram weight. So if I weigh 70 kilograms, then I would, that would be the
starting dose of hypermectin. The starting dose of hypermectin would be 35 milligrams per day.
And then if the cancer is continuing to spread, or it's not improving, the objective tests
mean I did another CT scan x-ray MRI to prove that it's improving, or you're looking at objective tests,
or you're looking at lab work, you're, you're, you're comparing it to subjective and objective
data that I'm improving. If I was improving and I was doing much better, then I would say, yeah,
well, you could definitely pulse off the hypermectin. That's certainly reasonable. If I wasn't,
then you actually go up to one milligram per kilogram weight. So you have to calculate your weight,
pounds, looking up on the computer, pounds, two kilogram conversion chart. So let's say, again,
for example, let's say I weighed 70 kilograms. If I was going to take one half milligrams per
kilogram weight, that would be the starting dose of hypermectin for cancer. I would be
starting at 35 milligrams. And if I wasn't improving, I'd go up to one kilogram per kilogram weight.
So I'd go up to 70 milligrams. You know, you're not even really, I don't know exactly what your weight is,
but you may not be at even one starting dose hypermectin. As far as the continuing on the fed
method dropping off the hypermectin, I understand that some people want to do that because
it may be more difficult to obtain hypermectin than it is fed-bed. However,
at least in our experience, fed-bed has been more of a culprit to cause liver and kidney issues.
So my rule of thumb is that if you're going to be on fed-bed and hypermectin, you really need to
be doing a comprehensive metabolic profile on a regular basis because you want to be looking at
your kidney markers and your liver markers. You don't want you to end up having
kidney failure or liver failure while trying to kill cancer. So you have to be looking at that too. Now,
if you did that and you're, you're created in your BUNR with a normal range and doing normal
functional range and your AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatases all within normal range and I'd say you're
fine in continuing to increase fed-bed dissolved. But again, you don't choose to increase fed-bed dissolved
based upon anything but objective and subjective data meeting that I'm, you know, I'm not improving.
So I'm going to increase the dosage or I am improving and I'm doing really well. So I'm going to
decrease the dosage. So I would base it upon that. So maybe we should have a discussion about this
to clarify. I have three programs set up on my computer for my true rife foot bath. Two of them
work great, but the third one only lights for approximately half the time. Also the water is not
dark when I'm finished with that time allotted. Does this mean it's not working for the entire time?
Yet probably does mean it's not working for the entire time.
For both the true rife and the interior Robin foot bath, if your, if the program stops working
halfway through, that's usually a sign that there's too much salt in the water.
And you might want to start over with less salt. I understand the three foot bath programs that I
put in your program for true rife users. You're not bound by that. You could go to the iron
pro wave folder and start using those programs. So if I were you, I just wouldn't stop using that
third one and do some other programs that you see appropriate for you in the iron pro wave folder.
But if with the, with your iron pro wave or your, until your Robin foot bath, if you have that,
if it stops working halfway through, that's usually an indication that you have too much salt in
the water. Well, how much salt am I supposed to put in the water? It depends on how hard your water is.
So if your water is really hard, meaning you have a lot of minerals in your water,
like calcium and other earth minerals and iron and such, you're going to need less salt because salt
is the helps the conductivity through the water. If you are using reverse as most as water,
which you shouldn't be, but that's pretend your water is really pure like reverse as well.
So since you're going to have to put more salt in the water. So you're just going to have to play with
everybody is different. There's no way to know that and tell you do that. So
now some people might be listening to this and go, I have an atelier Robin. How come I didn't get
a foot bath? Because I don't recommend them for atelier Robin users users. The reason why I
recommended them for true rife users and quite honestly it's a small percentage of true rife users
that use it. But true rife you can only go up to 10,000 hurts with atelier Robin you go up to
30,000 hurts. You don't really need a foot bath unit. So hopefully that answers that question.
Next question. Why do you recommend that I take certain supplements 30 minutes away from food?
Because it's typically I recommend you take a binder 30 minutes away from food or a homeopath.
So homeopaths are basically frequencies of items. So you might take a homeopath of mercury.
I want to take mercury. Well, guarantee if you bring it to an organic chemistry lab,
there's no mercury in that. It's the frequency of mercury. And by taking that away from food,
you're not allowing food to interrupt that. And you're taking that to stimulate your body to
interact with mercury. In the case of mercury homeopath, it's helping pull mercury out of your
body and such. As far as a binder goes, you want a binder to bind garbage that your liver has
dumped into the colon. You don't want your binder to bind the minerals that you just ate.
So the idea of taking things away from food is that it won't affect the effected by something
that you just ate. I'm really struggling doing the coffee enemas since I have a hard time lying down
and getting back up. Is that bad that I'm not doing that? Well, I understand doing the coffee enemas
the proper way, quote unquote, is that you're lying down, laid on one side and laid on back
on your back and laid and you're going to get up and go to the bathroom. But it's just it can be a mess,
right? And if we difficult getting up and off the floor and off the bed and then you know all this
kind of stuff. And guess what happens when things are difficult, we tend not to do them, right?
That's why in your on the member site, I posted Dr. Cutters easy peasy ways to do coffee enemas,
where you're just you're not doing it where you're lying down, you could do it in the shower,
you could leave your end of a bag hanging in the shower, you could do it in the shower while you're
standing and then step out to avoid it and then step back into the shower, clean off any mess you have
and you're good to go. And then guess what? It's easy to do. And you're 10 you're going to tend to
continue to do something that's easy to do. And again, you know, are you effectively
stimulating the vagal nerve doing it that way? If you talk to some die hard coffee enemas people
that say, no, you're going to do it the right way. Why? Because this is the way we're taught to do it.
Well, from way back when in the early 1900s, okay? But you really think in physiology,
you're just trying to get the caffeine up into your rectum to affect where the vagal nerve surfaces
in your rectum. I think you can do that standing up as well as you do that lying down. So now I know
there may be people that comment, do I try to that way? And I know that I get better effect if I
lie down. Well, go ahead and continue to lie down. But for the 90% of us who that's more
difficult to do, and you're quite honestly, you're just not going to do it if you're going to have to
do it that way. I'm the first one to raise my hand there. I did it the easy peasy way all the times
that I've ever done coffee enemas. And guess what? I think I had just as good of effect. You're trying
to stimulate the vagal nerve, cranial nerve tend in the rectum. That is your parasympathetic stimulation.
There's only a few places that you can stimulate the parasympathetic system externally. What is in
your ear? It's very difficult to find that spot and what is in your in your rectum. And it's easy
to get that spot using coffee enemas as your stimulant. So the whole purpose of a coffee enemas to
stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system, which controls rest and relaxation for your heart.
It will decrease blood pressure. It'll calm you. It'll calm your brain. It'll decrease inflammation
of your brain. It'll stimulate your immune system. It'll stimulate your detoxification pathways.
So all these great benefits of your stimulating your parasympathetics. And don't forget my blog post
and video on how there are ways that you can stimulate parasympathetics. Just search sympathetic
stimulus parasympathetic on the website. I have that information also on the member site and on some
of the courses. And it gives you functional neurology helps on how to stimulate the parasympathetics.
And some functional neurology helps have how to calm the sympathetic or the sympathetic's are
housed in a part of the midbrain called the messencephalon. So I think that I titled that paper
how to calm the messencephalon. So and then the other paper is how to stimulate the vagal urn.
So look at those. Some of them seem really kind of weird, but they're straight neurology.
So they can be very helpful. They can be very helpful with anxiety. I know a lot of people with
serious diseases have a you know have an issue with anxiety. And a lot of people
anxiety is the serious disease that they have an issue with. You know, we're selling in this
country more antidepressants and anti-medications than anything on the planet. And if we could just
calm our messencephalon and stimulate our parasympathetic system, we would be so far ahead. So don't
take for granted the the simpleness of those things and misunderstand that they're not extremely
powerful because they are. They're extremely powerful. So I challenge you to to not
to to overlook those things. So so look at that blog post.
My blood test showed an elevated BUN. What does that mean?
Okay. So your BUN is your blood urea nitrogen. It's a it's a marker that reflects
basically your how you break to how you metabolize protein and and it really is looking at
kidney function. So urea is the primary component of the blood urea nitrogen that we're looking at
here. It's urea is formed in the liver and it's an end product of the breakdown of protein in your
body. And then it's excreted in the kidney. So that's why it's really a kidney marker.
So if you have elevated BUN levels, it can indicate, you know, issues with your kidney. So it can
indicate readle impairment. It can indicate, you know, readle insufficiency, which means your
your kidneys are just being stressed, long-term elevated blood urea nitrogen can indicate
readle disease. You can have it increase in BUN if you're dehydrated.
It's funny how a lot of markers will change with dehydration. So if a person is dehydrated,
certainly you're going to have an elevated BUN. And it's really because it's really a relative
elevation of BUN because you have less fluid being excreted.
Hypocloridria, meaning decreased stomach acid, could elevate BUN. That's another
component somebody asked last week about using bicarbonate, whether it's potassium bicarbonate or
sodium bicarbonate as a quote-unquote cancer treatment because you'll see that in some old literature.
You'll see that in, you know, some clinicians still advocate for that, which is ridiculous.
And some, a lot of people on the internet, you'll see that on the internet.
Don't believe everything you see on the internet. So I can tell you how many, you know,
Facebook posts or videos that I see on the internet that are just
bonkers. So I saw what I mentioned last week when somebody asked that question about bicarbonate.
And this is the cheapest medicine. No demand. Simply take baking soda and put it in water and drink it.
It's so good for helping stomach acid issues. So I'm about like, oh my gosh, just absolute ridiculousness.
It's that's what causes hypocloridria. That's what's going to cause H. Pylori overgrowth and
infections that cause a lot of diseases. It's just harmful for you. So hypocloridria can cause
can be another cause of elevated B. U. N. Different diets can cause an elevation of B. U. N.
People on a carnivore diet can have an elevated B. U. N. That's one of the things that you have to
look at on a carnivore diet. I'm not against using a carnivore diet for somebody who has
serious autoimmune disorders where a lot of people with serious autoimmune disorders have
heavy damage to their gut and a lot of inflammation of their gut. And they have hypersensitivity.
They have developed antibodies to a ton of different foods. We've got a Cyrix 10 on people with
serious autoimmune diseases. And it's not about what they can't eat. It's about what they can't eat
because there's like five things that they can eat. I mean, that's what I've seen Cyrix 10 were
out of, you know, 100 different things tested for antibodies. Literally 95 are positive.
It's like, oh my gosh, this guy's this person. Typically that person has crows disease or something
like that. And putting them on a carnivore diet because many times it's only meat that they can eat
can be really helpful. You've heard of different celebrities that have been healed from their autoimmune
disease being on a carnivore diet. Well, they're actually able to calm things down and try to heal
other things if they're not having to deal with this fire in the gut. But what you have to look at
with those people is you have to keep an eye on their blood urea and nitrogen level because they're
going to have excess protein consumption because it's all they're consuming and they're breaking down
this protein and that's what can cause that. Other things that can cause elevated BUN can be
excess adrenal stress can cause elevated BUN. Really damaged guts, dysbiosis. If you have
really bad edema, swelling, you know, from something, from, you know, acides can elevate your BUN.
And then if you have anterior protuitar function dysfunction, you could have elevated BUN because you're
just not retaining things. So there's a lot of things that can cause elevated BUN to depends on
what else is going on. And remember, you don't just look at one marker. You look at one marker in
conjunction with other markers because, okay, so if I have, if I'm suspected, I'm elevated BUN and
could it be hypochloridria? Well, typically if you have elevated BUN and an increase in MCV and
increase in MCH and maybe a decrease or normal calcium, a decreased iron, a decreased alkaline
phosphatase, a decreased chloride, then you'd suspect more so that it's caused from hypochloridria.
But you're also going to look at not just in comparison to other markers. You have to look at
it in comparison to what's going on in that person's light. So if there have an elevated BUN and they're
taking a medication, let's say Ben Ben or Ivermectin, then you have to, you know, you're putting out
your Sherlock home hat here. You have to investigate all the possible causes of this change in marker
level and that's how you come to a working diagnosis. So if nothing else changes this person's life,
it was a normal BUN for a month ago and now they started taking this medication and now it's elevated.
Okay, well, you know, we're going to rule things out. It's quite possible. This from this medication,
maybe we should reduce that and see if that changes it. So that's how you come to, you know, answer a
question like that blood test showed an elevated BUN. What does that be? How come my oncologist doesn't
run two marker tests as a standard protocol? Good question. I think they should.
But I think I could only guess, but I think they don't run two marker tests because they're assuming
that you're going to do it, they're telling you to do, which is typically, if you're going to
do an oncologist, you have cancer and typically they're going to recommend chemotherapy.
If you're running tumor marker tests and you do chemotherapy and you run those tumor marker tests
again, when you're doing chemotherapy or shortly thereafter, typically you're going to have an
elevation of those tumor markers even though there's die off of the cancer because tumor markers are
proteins, they're blood markers that are proteins that certain cells can give off. Even if you don't
have cancer, you have a, you know, your tumor markers are going to be zero because all cells under
metabolic that are metabolizing can give off these proteins. So your tumor markers will never be
zero even if you don't have cancer. So even somebody without prostate cancer can still have a PSA
of two or four and that's still within normal range. Well, why if it doesn't have cancer, it's still
giving off that tumor marker because it's a protein that is given off by normal cells also but if the
cell is rapidly replicated, they have the ability to give off those more so or if a cancer that is
dying and being destroyed can spill those. So if a person is doing chemotherapy, it can spill more tumor
marker chemicals, those enzymes, those proteins and then it will read higher and then the person will
freak out. Why do I do this chemotherapy? I see a 1999 went up during the middle of my chemotherapy,
and the doctor has to explain, no, no, no, it's just because the cancer cells are dying and it's
spilling out this and now it's reading higher and then the patients confused and the patients man
and upset that you have to talk this person off the cliff. That's my, I can be totally wrong but
that's my theory on why they don't do because they can be very beneficial in giving a person an idea of
if their care is going well except if you're doing chemotherapy. So if you're doing chemotherapy,
don't run a tumor marker panel, it's worthless. If you stopped chemotherapy four months ago
and now you want to run it then that's fine but you kind of got to start with a new baseline.
So that's the only thing if you're doing chemotherapy, tumor markers are kind of dull and void,
not always but mostly most of them are going to be dull and void and I think that's why a
college is are expecting you to do exactly what they tell you. I mean most people do and if that's the
case you're running, you're doing chemotherapy and that makes two of our first kind of obsolete.
I choose to do, I chose to do radiation therapy before finding out about your clinic and I had a
terrible side effects. Is there anything I could do to help with these or detox from that?
Yeah, I think it really sent me back. So we have radiation, holiopaths, we have one that we create
in our office, it's just called radiation, holiopaths, and we have another one from PHP called
Radalind, I think it's called. You can take both of those, other key laders and other binders will
help pull that out of your body but to help with the side effects you have to heal whatever the
damage was. Let's say if you did radiation to the breast and it affected your heart, you're going
to have to do some things to help heal heart tissue. If you did, if you had radiation the breast
that helped the lung, you would do something different to help lung tissue. If you had radiation
the prostate and it damaged your colon wall, your rectal wall, then you'd have to do things to help
heal that. So it depends on where the damage is. So you're going to have to do damage control to
whatever, you know, whatever was injured by the therapy. But as far as detoxing radiation, because
radiation can stay in your system for a long, long time forever basically and continue to do damage.
So detoxing from that is important as well. So yeah, so contact me if that's wherever this wasn't
we can talk about some different things depending on what damage is done. I ran the six hour parasite
program on February 2nd. The next day I could barely move. I understand this was a herximer reaction
but I'm still struggling to function today. February 12th, moving, getting dressed, very weak,
pain in left arm, from a vestectomy, worse, etc. So this person, the person who submitted this,
we haven't heard from for a long, long time. So I don't know what else is going on in this person's
life. So I wouldn't like for this person to send up a time to talk to me. But I put the question in
here anyhow because I thought it would be helpful for everybody. So running a parasite program can a person
develop a herximer reaction. Remember what the definition of a herximer reaction is?
Herximer reaction was described by a doctor herximer. I don't know what a year ago. I don't know the
history of that. But it's described as when you do something a therapy, whether it's the right
machine or it's supplement or it's a medication and you end up producing a lot of endotoxins. So an
endotoxin is something that we, a word that we use to describe a toxin that is
coming from the inside of you. So endovines inside. So typically it'd be described as,
let's say you're killing a single cell organism. So if you're killing a single cell organism like a
bacteria, you're killing it by the cell going through a cell lysis. So the cell is being broken down.
And it's not your cell. So it's going to produce waste. So that cell is basically imploding and it's
like blowing up. And now where's that stuff going? Where's all that waste going? Well, it's going to
go back into your lymph system, into your beetle system, into your veins and it has to go in, try
to get out through your liver and your kidneys. And if it overwhelms your liver detoxification pathways,
it's going to circulate in your body and it's going to be deposited elsewhere and it's going to
just make you feel like flu-ish and make you feel icky. Now, if you feel that way from running
one parasite program, or if you did a medication, let's say, to kill parasites, or if you did a
supplement parasite supplement program to kill parasites, and you feel that way 10 days later,
I don't think it's a herxide reaction because it's not going to be circulated in your body for 10 days.
It's just, whoa, it'll be pushed into extracellular spaces. It can't stay in your blood that long. It can't.
So I don't think this is a herxide reaction. I don't think you're properly diagnosing what's going on.
Well, it happened right after the parasite program. That's what it happened. Maybe. I don't know.
I still don't think it's a herxide reaction. You could have some infection. You could have something
else going on. It was coincidental. But this is a word of caution to everybody. If you feel like you
have, you know, Lyme disease, so the worst thing that you're going to get a herximer reaction from
is going to be a gram negative bacteria. Now, there's different bacteria that are gram positive and
there's different bacteria that are gram negative. The most common gram negative bacteria that's
going to cause a herximer reaction is going to be Borrelia burgodorphine. Remember what that is?
That's Lyme disease. Well, it's part of Lyme disease. And my book Lyme disease is Borrelia burgodorphine
and then a bunch of other cold infections because almost nobody is only infected with that bacteria.
They're infected with that and other bacteria and other viruses called co-infections when you're
infected with Lyme disease. But it is the gram negative bacteria that would produce the greatest
herxer reaction. Why? Because the gram negative bacteria have in their cell membrane a chemical
called a lipopolysaccharide. Lipopolysaccharides are extremely toxic to us humans, to really anything.
And when they're liberated by you killing a gram negative bacteria, it liberates into the blood
stream, damages your lipopolysaccharides, damage your blood barrier, lipopolysaccharides,
are extremely toxic in our blood and we can get sick. That's really what a herximer reaction is.
If you're killing it at Miba, if you're running the parasite program, the parasite program on the
right, this person has a true right, the parasite program on the true right has not run any
gram negative bacteria programs. It's only running parasites. So a parasite, there's a single cell
organisms that are parasites, but they're not gram negative bacteria, so they're not liberating
their lipopolysaccharides. That's where you're going to get the most extreme herximer reactions.
Now, that being said, most people, let's say I got a herxer reaction,
our misdefining that I'm getting too long and my answer to the question, but I do want to address
this. Many people let's say I get herximer reactions really bad. It's really done a herximer reaction.
You're getting an autoimmune reaction. Just say a large percentage of people that think they're
getting herximer reactions have been told that it's a herximer reaction by a practitioner.
Many times it's an autoimmune reaction. They have antibodies to self-tissue and somehow
they're stimulating damage to that self-tissue. Many times when they have herxer reactions,
antibodies to neuronal tissue. And if you get a lot of herximer reactions, one thing that is
wise to do is to run a Cyrex 5 and especially a Cyrex Array 7x, 7x test to see if you have
antibodies to neuronal tissue. Because many times the thing that we think is a herximer because we
feel that way is actually inflammation or damage to neuronal tissue causing spirally inflammation
in the brain. And that could become very serious. So it's something to address. So looking at
Cyrex Array 7x will tell us definitively if that is the case. Now some that may need before you end
up with neuronal antibodies, you'll get microglial priming. And that could give you the exact same
symptoms too. I do have a video about this. I've shared this multiple times, but if you go to our website
and you look up a neurological inflammation, I think that's one of these neurological inflammation.
And you'll see a host that says neurological inflammation and microglial priming have a 30-minute
video that explains that in detail. And it goes into detail what prime microglial cells are and
explains that. Getting a Cyrex Array 7x test would help with that. That is the end point of that.
So when you get inflammation of the brain, have a history of Lyme disease, you get microglial
priming. It can lead to neurological antibodies being created. And that's a very serious
condition that you want to get ahead of and stay on top of and work towards correcting. It's not
you can't correct it completely, but you can manage it. So we have to get a little bit more detail
of this. Next question. I finished my second month
testing for joe tippins. So this person, joe tippins protocol is a Fennbedozole protocol. So they're
on Fennbedozole. And they're talking about testing because I'm asking people if you're taking Fennbedozole
and or hyperbactin that you run the comprehensive metabolic profile at least. So the first month,
kidney markers on the comprehensive metabolic profile were off. This month, kidney numbers are
back in line, though the BUN and the BUN creatinine ratio is off more than the first month. So this
person did give me the ranges. Their ALT and AST was normal. That alkaline phosphatase the first
month was 71. Now it's back down to 44. So 71 is even within oral range, but now it's lowered yet.
And their BUN was 23. Now it's 21. Now understand the difference between lab ranges and functional
ranges. So any lab could give you any range that they are deemed normal or abnormal. But for functional
medicine, understanding the functional ranges are much tighter. So the functional ranges,
the functional high BUN is actually 15. So even your 21 is still outside of functional range.
Now let me finish the question here because I think she addresses that. Funny thing is the different,
I use different labs. I have a new year new insurance, so different reference ranges. Yes, so different
labs can use different reference ranges. By BUN would still be considered high under the first lab range,
but is in range with this lab. I explained that. But really your functional lab range of BUN
is really 0 to 15. That's really considered normal range. Or you could say 0 or 10 to, excuse me, 10 to
15, but really 10 to 16. So 10 to 16 is the functional range of BUN. So even at 21, you're still high.
Creativity was within normal range. Following first labs, we pulsed, fed vendors and fed vendors all
two weeks on two weeks off. And I've been taking 222 milligrams two times daily. Still did that on
by on two weeks. What are your thoughts now? Keep pulsing, fed vendors all. My evermectored was 32
milligrams twice daily. Not pulsing that yet. Personally, I still think your BUN is too high.
And it did it if it only came down one point. That's within, you know, abnormal readings or two
points. That's still that's not the still kind of within abnormal range, especially would use the
different lab. I would consider, so it partly depends. So should I stop doing this protocol
at risk of damaging my kidneys? Well, you know, if my cancer, the part of the decision-making process,
if my cancer is growing like crazy, you know, and I have to do something, then you have to decide
the risk and reward in this. And gosh, by BUNB23 and down to 21, is that really, you know,
causing damage to my kidneys? Well, I don't know. What is your normal? Maybe your normal was
11 before all this. I don't know. But it's, you know, you just have to weigh out that risk and reward.
If you're, if you're answered to that question, it's, well, no, my cancer wasn't going crazy.
I thought it was fairly stable. And I just wanted to try this to see if I could really knock it down.
Did I, personally, I would consider going off of it for a month and see if I could bring those
levels down a little bit and then try it. I don't know, you're going to make that decision. You
call me, we could talk that over. But that's kind of how you go through that decision-making process,
I think. Okay, back to the questions you guys said, text. I've been reading that,
milk this, and I talked about that. One of the benefits of LDN. LDN is low dose,
no trixone, no trixone was initially a drug that was issued for the help of getting off of heroin,
I think, and some other, you know, street drugs. But it was approved at 50 milligrams. So
low dose, no trixone is starting at 1.5 milligrams and going to 3 milligrams and going to 4.5
maximum milligrams. That's considered, that's considered low dose, no trixone. It was fun to be a
immune system regulator, a T-reg stimulator is what a technical terminology is.
So remember, you have these two sides of your immune system, this inflammatory side,
this anti-inflammatory side. And they're not good or bad, they're both good, with imbalance.
And a time of an immune up regulation to kill pathogens, you have this TH1 hyperfunction,
your TH2 system suppress, and you have this more inflammatory but deadly immune response to kill
something. And people that have autoimmune disease can have this bounce back and forth and can be stuck
at a TH1 dominance and cause damage to cells that you have antibodies against like the Hashimoto's
or MS, where you have antibodies against violence. Sheat cells are stuck at a TH1 dominance, you're
continually progressively damaging that which you have antibodies against. And if it's self-tissue,
that's not good. Well, you have what's called a T-reg system in your body. That means it regulates
this TH1, TH2 response and brings it back into balance. And there's different nutrients that are
that are T-reg nutrients. Vitamin D has been found to be here, but take vitamin D if you're
got a cold because it's a great immune stimulator. Well, that's not actually true. Vitamin D is a
team reg stimulator. So it helps balance and out of balance immune response. Some people get sick
all the time because they're stuck at a TH2 dominance. So taking T-reg stimulators can help bring that
back into balance so that your TH1, TH2 system will work more balanced and correctly.
Medicinal mushrooms, they're great immune stimulators. Not really, they're immune regulators,
they're T-reg stimulators. So if you're out of balance where you don't have a good immune response,
they will help boost that immune response. If you're out of balance and you have too much
immune response, aka an autoimmune disorder, they'll help bring that down. LDN does that as well.
So low dose DLT is a drug that can be a T-reg stimulator. Well, why don't we use that more often
for cancer? Because it is a drug and it has side effects. So to be it shines more with people with
serious autoimmune disease than it does with people with cancer. So that helps. Next question, how long
should I wait to put the bulb under the covers? I started this past Sunday night and you suggested I
start with it under the bed. Well, because you said you were prone to having works out of a reaction.
So you don't, you're trying to try to just start slowly. If you're like, no, I'm having no trouble
whatever. Well, then put it up in bed but leave it a little bit farther away from you and then slowly
move it closer to you. So you can play with it. You can play with it. You can start with an embedded
if you wake up in the middle of the night. You just kind of feel like it's kind of knocking your
socks off and slipping under the bed. So just play with it. I just want you to be safe.
And this person who's asking the question has an atelier Robin. Remember, you have to be a little
more careful with that because versus the true right because it puts out three times the energy.
So with people with the true right, they're wondering why I'm answering this question this way.
And I am always told people with the true right just to put it in your bed,
struggle with it, you're going to be fine. And 99.9% of the time that's true. But unless you have
lime, then you'd ever do that. But if you have the atelier Robin, you might sometimes want to go
a little slow. For Ademia, can you use your bed covered with a heavy towel? I show very easy.
For an animal, can you use your bed covered with a very heavy towel? Very easy. Absolutely.
So if it's if you do the animal for you is just fine, do it at the normal way on your bed, then you
go for it. Yep, that's great. That's fantastic. I did put my normal BUN and created in the question
quite a bit higher than my pre-joke tippin's protocol. Then I would say, going back to, you know,
my cancer isn't like screaming and growing, then I might want to just pause this for a month.
And I just you don't want to damage your kidneys. Your kidneys are a hard organ to heal.
And it probably talked to 90% of doctors are like, okay, BUN of 23, you're not going to
damage your kidneys. But again, you just don't want to risk. Your liver can actually
grow back, but your kidneys can't. So your kidneys don't. But again, my cancer was growing like crazy.
And I'm trying to put on the stops of it, then I maybe take that risk. So it just depends on where you're
at. I've tested well with Oshwagandha for a while. So I assume it's okay for me. But what is the
issue with hormone positive breast cancer? There's some studies that have shown that Oshwagandha
in some people can stimulate estrogens as well. So I'm going to have some estrogenic effect on some
people, not with them. What are the side effects of LDN that we have to look for? I don't know.
In the member site, I have a link to Drugs.com. And you can put that in there and you can see any side
effects on that. I have my true life in for repairs. I'll try to look at Attilia Robin website. Yeah,
their website is horrible. Look at the stuff on our site. So I'm obvious what to get. Do you
provide a list of components? Yeah, you just call the office and Raid could talk to you about that.
If a person bought an Attilia Robin from Attilia Robin, they're in Canada. You don't get any
frequencies. You get no programs. You can download the F100 program. There's no frequencies, zero.
It's not like a true one. So yeah, Raid can talk to you about it. Okay, good questions today.
Thanks for being on another great Zoom call.
Remember to get your questions in. If you can think of them, leave before you can make sure we
get them answered. And God bless all of you. I'll be praying for you guys. Talk to you next week.